continuing our desert survival series
tonight a lot of people mistakenly think
as long as they have their cell phone
when hiking they'll be able to call for
help but that may not always be the case
joining us is lana mcveigh she is with
red rock search and rescue highly
qualified for this let us know about uh
cell phone service people grab their
cell phones what should they know before
they head out to the desert do their
hiking
well they should know if they've got
cell service or not but they should
always prepare that they don't have
self-service and there's a lot of ways
that they can prepare to go on a hike
still know their navigation still know
where they're going and not have cell
phone service
and one way you know is always to have a
garmin or if you have the capability to
have a garmin
you have to know how to use your garmin
and you have to have spare batteries for
your garmin device but cells cell phones
smartphones specifically now
have gps capabilities built into them
and a lot of people don't know that but
they have gps capabilities that work
even when the self does not have service
and even when um your point your phone
is in airplane mode